bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 14
septembre merci de nous pour vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau journal
d'information tout de suite on commence
avec les titres de votre actualité
locale
bougez autrement jusqu'au 22 septembre
se tient en europe la semaine de la
mobilité de nombreux rendez vous au
programme et notamment sur saint quentin
en yvelines invités notamment maylis
fleurier responsable du service des
nouveaux usages des mobilités pour la
communauté d'agglomération jéhovah en
grève les salariés basés à
montigny-le-bretonneux de la société
allemande spécialisée dans la conception
et la fabrication d'équipements
industriels étaient en grève aujourd'hui
10% des effectifs serait menacé suite à
la réorganisation du groupe
la fête de l'huma mais aussi la place du
parti communiste français pour les
prochaines régionales nous vous en
parlerons également ce soir avec julien
iborra secrétaire dans les yvelines de
la formation politique
il est en plateau avec nous mais pour
commencer tout de suite dans cette
actualité aujourd'hui nous revenons sur
l'arrivée des réfugiés syriens et
irakiens dans les yvelines à versailles
une soixantaine de réfugiés en
provenance d'allemagne sont attendus
cette semaine pour l'instant aucune date
n'a encore été arrêtée quant à leur
arrivée c'est le centre d'hébergement
d'urgence des mortemets qui a été
choisie par la préfecture la croix-rouge
s'occupe des préparatifs mais d'autres
associations caritatives se tiennent
prêtes à agir comme le collectif
versailles solidarité internationale qui
rassemble 21 associations caritatives on
écoute tout de suite philippe domergue
et réponses constable responsable pardon
de ce collectif nous avons lancé un
appel à l'accueil des réfugiés sur
versailles
en ce qui concerne les personnes qui
peuvent se proposait eh bien nous les
orientons vers telle ou telle
association qui
dont nous savons qu'ils ont des besoins
et y aura une action donc administrative
puisqu'ils vont être là d'abord pour
faire une demande d'asile et régulariser
leur situation
et puis pour certains et malheureusement
pour beaucoup il va y avoir donc
probablement une même matériel
on attend un petit peu que le dispositif
soit soit organisée parce que pour être
efficace effectivement il faut pas se
disperser dans tous les horizons et je
vous le disais nous allons parler de la
fête de l'humanité ne sommes pas tous
avec julien iborra secrétaire
départemental du parti communiste
français d y viennent bonsoir à vous et
merci des bonus notre plateau pour
répondre à nos questions alors la fête
de l'humanité vient de se terminer tout
à l'heure je le dis dans les titres deux
cent mille personnes c'est par jour en
tout il n'ya plus de voiles à 400 500
mille personnes qui sont mes six cent
mille personnes qui sont venues qui sont
rendus donc à la courneuve
comment ça s'est passé pour vous sur les
stands des yvelines il y avait un regain
d'intérêt pour les particuliers français
oui bien sûr c'est un rendez vous
traditionnel la fête de l'humanité c'est
tous les ans depuis 80 ans
une fête une fête populaire une fête
culturelle une fête politique et cette
année comme une autre il y avait
beaucoup de monde malgré malgré le temps
cap à cap a repoussé tous les gens qui
avaient pris leur place a plus sa place
avant pardon et nous la lui l'occasion
de rencontrer des centaines d'oubli noah
sur notre stand à tous l'occasion toute
cette lettre c'est ça qui a fait 150
donc parti communiste des différentes
régions font ce qu'ils sont qui sont
représentés ya juste un stand yvelinois
alors que par exemple dans le veston de
d'ile-de-france fait 94 et 93
val-de-marne et la seine-saint-denis
était beaucoup plus a représenté une
exception comme en bas c'est assez
simple le val de marne c'est un
département communiste où le parti
communiste est extrêmement fort la seine
saint denis ça a été jusqu'en 2008 un
département comme nice tout le parti
communiste encore très très fort
l'histoire du parti communiste dans les
yvelines est un peu plus compliquée du
fait de la couleur politique du
département
donc c'est pas excusez moi il faisait
très froid
c'est normal qu'ils aient un petit peu
moins de monde ça veut pas dire qu'on
est nous a motivés c'est juste qu'on a
un tout petit plus nombreux que dans ces
départements on va là c'est un poids le
poids
minimes dans tout l ensemble du parti
communiste français oui alors de là à
parler du poids des yvelines ça voudrait
dire qu'on est en concurrence avec les
autres il ya un seul parti communiste
qui rayonne sur toute la france
alors il ya des communistes dans les
yvelines qui sont moins nombreux que
dans d'autres départements pour autant
on peut pas parler de poids d'un
département par rapport à un autre
on l'a vu un lien l'instant que nous
parlions à des migrants qui sont arrivés
dans les yvelines justement voilà c'est
un grand sujet de société en ce moment
c'était également une problématique
était au coeur de la fête de l'huma
manucure et d'ailleurs a chanté la
chanson que l'addition
bien sûr ben c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui est un sujet qui est fort pour
nous c'est la question de la question de
ce qui se passe dans le monde entier on
a un parti internationaliste et et voir
le drame de ces de ces migrants mais
surtout de ce qui se passe dans leur
pays à ce qui se passe quand ils
arrivent ici qui est extrêmement dur la
traversée mais c'est surtout ce qui se
passe dans leur pays la guerre la misère
c'est évidemment des questions qui sont
identitaire pour nous les communistes et
auquel on tâche de d'essayer de trouver
des réponses et par rapport justement au
positionnement de l'europe a envoyé la
semaine dernière l'allemagne sont les
ouvrir ses portes justement à ces
migrants aujourd'hui la pression a
changé
comment comment vous le jugez quelle est
votre position par rapport à ça
là dessus il faut une position
européenne il ya besoin de solution
politique à ce qui se passe c'est pas le
tout d'accueillir denis des migrants
c'est fondamental et la france ne joue
pas un rôle assez fort dans l'accueil
des migrants les annonces faites par
françois hollande la semaine dernière
sont très en deçà de la capacité
d'accueil de la france 24 milles c'est
il ya trente-six mille clown en france
ça fait moins de un par commune donc on
voit qu'il ya une capacité d'accueil
forte est sous utilisé mais pour autant
la vraie solution aller comment on règle
les problèmes qui existent dans ces pays
comment régler ce qui se passe en irak
comme en règle ce qui se passe en syrie
et comme on règle ce qui se passe
globalement en afrique parce qu'elle
aussi tous ces migrants qui fuient la
qui fut la misère
donc il ya des solutions que l'europe
peut trouver des solutions politiques
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut qu'il faut
se battre aussi et la progression
justement du parti a commise par rapport
voilà à ces migrants à ces réfugiés à
calais tél madame aujourd'hui dans une
urgence sociale à laquelle à laquelle il
faut répondre
donc il faut faire en sorte de pouvoir
accueillir dignement ces personnes mais
ça aussi ça fait écho à une activité à
une actualité politique en france
aujourd'hui les communes se sont fait
tellement saigner les budgets municipaux
sont des constantes alors que les
comme ils ont de plus en plus de choses
à faire que mais ce qu'il faut des
quotas ou est-ce qu'il faut instaurer
des quotas ou justement non moi je crois
pas je crois pas aux quotas moi je crois
que toute personne qui en souffrance
doit pouvoir être accueillis dignement
mais ça ça nécessite des moyens des
moyens importants j'entraînais notamment
à mes camarades qu'ils aient ce week-end
la fête de l'huma la solidarité n'est
pas soluble dans l'austérité
ça veut dire que là c'est un moment les
politiques d'austérité nous montre qu'
on ne peut plus faire face ni à la
misère de notre peuple et à répondre à
ceux qui sont dans le besoin qui ont
besoin de la france qui a toujours été
une terre d'accueil donc là il ya besoin
aussi de réorienter les politiques quand
on entend par exemple qu'en allemagne 1
million de réfugiés vont arriver c'est
sûr que voilà c'est une problématique à
prendre en compte comme évidemment
évidemment mais bien sûr mais il ya de
la place pour la place pour tout le
monde ya beaucoup de richesses
la france a jamais été aussi riche d'un
moment la question de la répartition des
richesses se pose avec force etc y
compris cette question des migrants doit
se traiter par les politiques nationales
j'aimerais à faire également un point
avec vous sur donc les élections
régionales
le département des yvelines contre un
seul conseiller régional comment vous
expliquer cette situation est ce que
vous allez pouvoir encore peser sur
cette élection qui arrive va on va peser
sur cette élection comme en fait à
toutes les élections avec nos idées avec
nos contenus politiques tout ce que l'on
peut porter et notamment pour cette
région ile de france on a des choses à
dire aussi une région qui est
extrêmement riche
c'est la région la plus riche de france
une des régions les plus riches du monde
et pour autant il ya de grosses
inégalités on voit saint quentin en
yvelines avec des villes comme trappe ou
la verrière où on a des populations qui
sont grandes souffrances mais qui côtoie
pas très loin des looks sienne le
vésinet où on a des populations qui sont
plus plus aisés donc c'est comment on
tire parti de cette diversité et qu'on
arrive à améliorer ça vous allez faire
des alliances vous allez c'est pesant
des alliances avec le parti socialiste
nous allons proposer à toute la gauche
de se rassembler sur des contenus
politiques forts des contenus politiques
forts ça veut dire refuser les
politiques d'austérité mettre en place
des politiques de solidarité continue
une partie de ce qui a déjà été fait je
pense notamment au dézonage de la carte
imagine r qui était une proposition des
élus communistes qu'on a obtenu de haute
lutte après cinq ans de bataille et
d'autres et d'autres d'autres choses
comme ça sur lesquels on se bat donc
nous tous qui pourra amener à plus de
solidarité à plus de fraternité entre
les franciliens voilà on met ça sur la
table
après il ya des choses avec lesquelles
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec le
parti socialiste une élection c'est à
deux tours
mais dans des dans des communes comme
par exemple trappe ou la verrière on a
vu parfois les non pas la résultante rap
que les électeurs se tourner plutôt vers
le front national que vers le parti
communiste dans ce cas là qu'est la
solution vous allez pouvoir mettre en
place pour inverser peut-être les
électeurs ils se tournent surtout vers
l'abstention c'est ça le principal
problème on l'a vu leurs dernières
élections comme le front national a
réalisé des scores importants disent
qu'on a vu lors des dernières élections
c'est que 70% des électeurs attrape se
sont abstenus c'est ça le drame de ça le
l'électorat du front national ne grandit
pas particulièrement c'est qu'en
proportion est morte parce que beaucoup
de beaucoup de citoyens aujourd'hui ne
se reconnaissent plus dans la politique
que se désintéressent de la politique et
c'est là le rôle du parti communiste
c'est de dire que la politique ça sert à
quelque chose c'est ce que je disais sur
la carte imagine r les élus ça sert à
quelque chose
donc il faut
il faut que nous les politiques on
retourne vers les citoyens peut-être
qu'on l'a un peu oublié ces dernières
années il faut qu'on retourne vers les
citoyens pas pour leur distribuer la
bonne parole mais pour les écouter
entendre ce qu'ils ont à dire et avec
eux construire un programme politique et
c'est à cette condition là mon avis on
redonnera confiance dans la politique et
que là les électeurs retourneront vers
les young et là vous verrez que le score
du front national
il serait dur à la portion congrue eh
bien nous suivrons avec nous justement
ces actualités l'actualité de ces
élections merci je viens y aura des
revenus avec nous et notre plateau et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sociales
à présent les salariés du groupe
industriel allemand gea se sont
mobilisés cet après midi sur le site de
montigny le bretonneux
la société spécialisée dans la
conception et fabrication d'équipements
industriels envisagent de supprimer une
centaine d'emplois en france et 10% des
effectifs du site de montigny le
bretonneux seraient concernés tout de
suite le reportage de fanny bourdillon
plus d'une centaine de salariés de
l'entreprise ga de montigny le
bretonneux se sont rassemblés ce lundi
après midi pour faire grève ils se
mobilisent contre un plan de
restructuration
débuté en août 2014 et qui met en péril
une trentaine d'emplois tout ça est très
mal vécue par là dans les collègues
il ya aussi un très forte incertitude
puisque en fait on a des services à la
fois désorganisé par des départs déjà
existants ou annoncés ou à venir il y a
vraiment cette eau sur la certitude
qu'ils créent de l'angoissé et l'anxiété
chez les salariés le groupe allemand
industriel gea possède quatre grands
centres en france dont celui de montigny
le bretonneux
c'est la première fois que les salariés
du site se met en grève depuis sa
création en 1996
le site de montigny n'a jamais connu de
mouvements sociaux à ma connaissance on
le le le site se porte très bien le
groupe gea se porte très bien de façon
mondiale se porte très bien au niveau
ici de l'entité gema process engineering
donc on n'avait pas de raison de d'être
inquiet avec un chiffre d'affaires de 5
milliards d'euros
les salariés estiment que le groupe n'a
pas besoin de revoir sa masse salariale
à la baisse une organisation syndicale
s'est donc créé il y a trois mois et
d'autres mouvements sociaux sont déjà
prévus la prochaine étape c'est cette
journée intersyndicale d'actions à le 24
septembre et est
pour ce qui est du site de montigny ça
sera dur à part une journée dure elle
qui a été déjà voté sauf si
on arrive à être entendu nous on n'est
pas des gens excessifs on est des gens
de dialogue
le problème pour dialoguer c'est comme
pour se marier faut être deux les
dirigeants de jeu et ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer à la presse avant le 17
septembre prochain jour où ils
rencontreront les représentants des
salariés pour débuter les négociations
et je vous disais en titre cette semaine
commence la semaine de l'art européenne
de la mobilité chez elle valorise le
partage de l'espace public et la
sécurité des usagers
les français sont invités à repenser
leurs modes de transport et à choisir
également autre chose que l'automobile
des moyens de transport alternatifs qui
renoue à cette occasion pour en parler
nous recevons deux invités en plateau
malice fleurier responsable du service
nouveaux usages et mobilité à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines bonsoir et armé le pitois
président de pouce yvelines à
l'association à l'origine du projet deux
premiers réseaux d'auto stop organisé en
ile de france
on saura vous nous y reviendrons dans
quelques instants je vais commencer avec
vous à malices fleurier l'agglomération
de saint quentin s'engage pour cette
semaine
ce que vous pouvez me résigner un petit
peu l'objectif voilà pour les saint
quentinois à quel est il
l'objectif de la semaine de la mobilité
c'est une semaine européenne
donc on incite tous les acteurs à faire
des propositions pour cette semaine là
en matière d'actions qui sont pour qu'on
se déplacer autrement qu'en voiture pour
tous ses déplacements
donc c'est les actions pour parler des
transports publics pour parler de la
marche à pied pour parler du vélo du
covoiturage tous les modes alternatifs
alors quelles sont les initiatives qui
sont mises en place voilà tout au long
de cette semaine
alors cette semaine on fait des
opérations on va dire de communication
et d'information sur les transports
en fait on a deux vagues d'événements
dès la semaine prochaine à partir enfin
cette semaine à partir du 15 septembre
ce mardi on va on vient dans les
entreprises parler de l'information sur
les transports dont convient avec les
transporteurs avec ski bus on vient avec
des opérateurs de covoiturage comme moi
hysope quand les entreprises ont choisi
pour répondre directement aux questions
de déplacement des salariés et après on
a une deuxième vague d'événements à
partir de la semaine prochaine
pendant cinq jours où là on fait des
rallyes à quai pour
bouger à pied pour faire ses
déplacements et découvrir un peu
l'environnement
donc il ya une action entreprise il ya
une action aussi hélas des stations
d'écouté citoyens des particuliers qui
est la plus importante il ya une un
besoin qu'il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
implantées sur le territoire de
mobiliser justement les entreprises sur
ce sujet alors la principale cible en
fait sur les déplacements c'est le
domicile travail
les déplacements du quotidien donc c'est
pour ça qu'on vient parler aux salariés
de comment quelles solutions peut vous
apporter pour mieux vous déplacer en bus
par exemple tous les jours donc ça c'est
la première cible
après pour nous c'est aussi important de
parler des autres modes de transport et
c'est pour ça qu'on fait une opération
la semaine prochaine qu'on appelle le
rallye de la mobilité
mais en fait vous avez une espèce de
chasse aux trésors des lieux a trouvé
dans un secteur votre quartier est en
fait faut se déplacer à pied pour se
rendre compte qu'on peut se déplacer
confère aussi les choses à pied qu'on
est pas obligé de te faire tout en
voiture donc voilà il faut justement
mobiliser les gens pour qu'ils essayent
de de prendre le vélo qu'il se déplace à
pied parce qu'ils ne sont pas souvent
prêts à abandonner à leur voiture
justement c'est la question que nous
avons posée à vous saint quentinois pour
quel mode de transport seriez vous prêt
à abandonner votre voiture ou d'arbres
pour qu'elle transporte seriez vous prêt
à quitter votre voiture
la twizy pourquoi pas le bus ou le tram
mais
voilà bon voilà aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
bus ou tram je prends jamais les
transports mais d'usagé pas le tramway
le vélo mais pas très bon à quoi ça ça
le tramway est quelque chose qui soit
parce que ça ne se fasse pas de bruit
pas des bus des bus tout ce que j'en ai
à côté de chez moi c'est plus pratique
plus là après les travaux j'ai pas de
voiture donc réservé l'eau donc c'est
très bien mais les bus mais avec plus de
buts dans le coin par contre avec plus
de correspondances parce que c'est vrai
que des fois il ya des attentes de 20
minutes à 30 minutes donc ça serait
mieux alors amélie tu vois on a vu
justement dans ce micro trottoir peu de
gens ont évoqué le l'auto-stop pourtant
c'est justement votre projet poussière
est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus
alors c'est de l'auto stop organisé ça
se base sur le principe de l'auto stop
sauf que on va essayer de le sécuriser
en fait le passage et les conducteurs ou
à lire et à l'association pause divine
que nous avons créée spécialement pour
ça ils vont recevoir en fait un badge
passagers un badge au conducteur c'est
comme une carte bancaire mais avec
l'éffigie de l'éffigie l'association et
nous allons aussi identifié des arrêts
sur la voirie alors en fait le point
c'est gratuit pour les utilisateurs
l'idée c'est que en fait ils
appartiennent à la même communauté
à partir de là il ya que 4 le projet
n'est pas le dispositif n'est pas encore
mise en place nom sera mis en place donc
aux au printemps prochain forçant vous
avez mis ce projet emplacement vous avez
contacté quatre communes pour apparaître
ce projet alors aujourd'hui en fait le
projet était je dirais un petit peu en
liées aux os la possibilité d'avoir des
une subvention de la région ile de
france que nous avons puisque nous avons
eu cinquante mille euros des régions île
de france et à partir de là en fait
comme on a eu cette réponse cet été
on est dans une phase en fait de
construction et de je dirais de
rencontres avec les communes pour
vraiment étendre ce réseau pour qu'il
soit vraiment pertinents donc pour que
justement le réseau soit personnel ou
que la taille qu'ils atteignent une
taille critique de plus de 80 communes à
il me semble ça alors pu y être communes
plus cjr efficient aujourd'hui non
on escompte rayonner sur plus de 140
communes tout simplement parce qu'en
fait on veut rabattre vers les
transports en commun on n'est pas là du
tout pour concurrencer les transports en
commun et on se structure autour en fait
un territoire qui et je dirai basé sur
le nord par la ligne
paris-mantes-la-jolie au sud paris
rambouillet mais ça sent blog des
communes du pnr à l'ouest ça va être les
limites de la région ile de france et à
l'est c'est tout le front urbain puisque
en fait le tout ce qui est feront leur
bain est bien desservi par les
transports en commun nous concrètement à
partir du printemps 2015
on peut venir vous voir se renseigner si
poussive in fonctionne sur la commune où
on habite
et c'est de mettre en place a pour
pouvoir emprunter un réseau vous ne
mettez en relation justement les
auto-stoppeurs et les gentils prénom en
voiture c'est autre chose
voilà exactement est en fait les gens
peuvent déjà aller voir sur le site de
réseau pouces puisqu'on va dupliquer un
dispositif qui existe dans le tarn et
garonne qui a déjà fait ses preuves sur
près de 90 communes et l'idée c'est
vraiment d'avoir je dirais à quelque
chose de cohérent au niveau territorial
et c'est gratuit pour les utilisateurs
j'essaie vraiment en fait construit avec
les collectivités pour apporter aux
collectivités une réponse de transport
de maillage géographiquement parlant et
puis aussi pour les usagers agir à avoir
une offre de transport dans la journée
dans des zones rurales où ils nous sont
desservies que le matin le soir
marie est ce que vous pensez justement
de cette intiative l'auto stop à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça vous semble
possible à mettre en place mais le
covoiturage en général on pense que
c'est une vraie solution saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est pour ça qu'on s'intéresse à toutes
les solutions qui se développent
actuellement parce que l'auto stop du
coup sa saveur est peut-être plus aux
jeunes way un certain public les retours
d'expérience qu'on a deux réseaux poussé
il ya deux catégories de personnes soit
privilégié ce sont les dans les zones
rurales les cons les foyers où il n'y a
qu'une seule voiture par foyer ou le
conjoint
une fois que le premier parti travailler
avec la voiture se retrouve en fait sans
voiture est donc là c'est ans j'ai
encore eu le cal alternatiba où j'ai
rencontré une personne qui vraiment
recherché ce type d'offre et puis la
deuxième la deuxième tranche ce sont les
lycéens que tout le monde voie entre le
jir a aujourd'hui sont desservis les
lycées sont desservies le matin le soir
très bien par les transports en commun
ou du moins du mieux que peu que peut le
faire la région et par contre si les
lycéens commence plus tard est où
finissent plus tôt ma foi ils font déjà
de l'auto stop mais dans des conditions
qui sont pas qu'ils sont à peu près des
docks mais plus sécurisé et bien toutes
les infos sur à la semaine de la
mobilité c'est sur le site de saint
quentin en yvelines
et pour pousser vinet vos stops c'est
sur le site également de pousser jean je
vous laisse découvrir ça merci à vous
donne peut-être venu avec nous en
plateau et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
samedi dernier la mairie de versailles
organisé son baby site dating de rentrer
après inscription les parents bénéficier
d'un créneau horaire précis pour
recevoir en entretien des jeunes qui se
présentent et librement un stage de
premiers secours a également été
proposée par la mairie pour former ses
futurs baby sitter un rendez-vous qui
marche pour cette sixième édition 150
parents étaient inscrits pour trouver le
baby sitter idéal williams elle a
rencontré des participants regardez
c'est une habituée en fait ça fait trois
ans que je viens et je crois je trouve
plein de personnes motivées et c'est
vrai que c'est difficile de trouver des
contacts par nous mêmes donc là ça
permet de rencontrer beaucoup de
personnes en peu de temps faut essayer
de saisir la motivation des personnes et
voir sur une adéquation au près dans les
dents les horaires saddam et d'avoir un
contact avec les parents de voir leurs
attentes et aussi de se présenter une
sorte de préliminaires je dirais
peut-être aux entretiens d embauche sous
une petite réunion pour plus tard
et ce soir comme chaque lundi nous
faisons un point sur la culture et la
culture locale agriculteurs avec un
autre journaliste sephora nam amis m'ont
soir à sephora alors il va être question
un festival ce soir exactement florennes
alors pour cette nouvelle chronique
culture on va parler du festival île de
france un festival qui existe depuis 39
ans mais qui reste encore assez méconnu
donc ce festival rassemble 450 artistes
de 20 nationalités différentes sur une
trentaine de concerts à travers 27 lieux
de l'île de france et ce jusqu'au 11
octobre
nous sommes allés à la rencontre
d'olivier delsey directeur du festival
île de france qui nous en parle c'est
avant tout un voyage aller vers un
voyage à travers différents répertoires
puisqu'on va vraiment de l'acier
jusqu'aux musiques actuelles aux
musiques du monde
et puis c'est un voyage un découvert de
l'île de france on s'installe sur 27
lieux se répartit sur l'ensemble du
territoire francilien est donc le public
peut à l'occasion des concerts découvrir
pas mal de création ce que c'est avant
tout un festival de création et des
lieux du patrimoine notamment des lieux
qui sont parfois peu souvent
ouvert au public ce week-end donc avait
lieu le premier concert y vino à l'habit
de port royal des champs
il s'agissait d'une lecture concert
d'après walden ou la vie dans les bois
de henry david thoreau il est question
d'une réflexion sur la condition de
l'homme et de la nature création
spécialement conçu pour le festival on
retrouve olivier ker ourio à l'arnica
kevin seddik et à la guitare et aux
percussions et jérôme imart pour
l'adaptation du texte on en écoute un
extrait ambitieux de la campagne dans
l'autre sens
voici alors justement cadre du festival
qui a pour but de faire découvrir le
patrimoine de la région
ce concert était à suivirent d'une
visite de la chapelle de la baie de port
royal des champs ça exactement fermé au
public depuis 30 ans elle a été
réouverte exceptionnellement pour
l'occasion
mon temps menacé de s'effondrer la
chapelle s'est offerte une nouvelle
toiture ce qui permet à nouveau
d'accueillir en toute sécurité les
visiteurs chapelle construite à la fin
du 19e siècle 1891 893 précisément pour
abriter les collections de port royal
elle collectionne encore aujourd'hui de
très beaux vitraux d'époque
la visite était commentée par philippe
us conservateur en chef du domaine de
port royal des champs
on rappelle que ce festival présente des
musiques de création aussi bien
classique etc actuelle et cherche à
faire rencontrer différents arts avec la
musique tels que la littérature dans le
cadre des lectures concerts de la vidéo
pour les ciné concerts et même le dessin
alors quelles sont les prochaines dates
à retenir justement pour ce festival
c'est fort alors date important que le
25 septembre big sound théâtre de saint
quentin spectacle invité au concert si
mischa sol qu'on a déjà annoncé qu'il
veut nous emmener voyager en martinique
et en guadeloupe
le dimanche 27 septembre également vidéo
concert à londres théâtre devises
villacoublay création doha où le lait de
l'ensemble télémaque autour du film king
kong
berne est chaude sac et enfin date phare
de ce festival
les 25 26 et 27 septembre retrouvera
youssou n'dour ou cirque d'hiver de
paris qui nous offrira ses morceaux en
avant première de son prochain album qui
sortira dans les bacs pour en 2016
on écoute un extrait de sa dernière
participation au festival île de france
voilà
et
nous m'avez bien
elle n'est pas nouveau
et vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations concernant le festival sur
le site www.festivaldumot.fr merci
sephora on vous retrouve mercredi pour
un nouveau numéro de kiosques l'émission
dédiée à la culture et nous allons
maintenant parler d'un autre festival ce
week-end la commune de montigny le
bretonneux organiser un festival autour
de l'automobile dans cette voiture était
à découvrir mais aussi les voitures du
futur notamment celles imaginées par les
étudiants de l'estaca autre
particularité de cette journée le
festival a consacré a tenu à rendre
hommage à jean pierre beltoise
l'ancien pilote décédé en janvier
dernier reportage de mélanie potier il y
avait bien sûr les voitures anciennes
ont croisé les voitures du futur mais
cette année le festival automobile de
montigny le bretonneux a rendu hommage
au pilote jean-pierre beltoise en
présence de sa famille
ça fait plaisir voilà qu'aujourd'hui la
mairie de montigny rend hommage à jean
pierre beltoise à notre papa ça voilà ça
prouve qu'il est toujours dans le coeur
blanc coeur des gens quand on était
gamin c'était venir ici au circuit des
caves et de la neige prendre une voiture
4 roues motrices et dans son dos allez
aller s'amuser à faire des contrôles des
dérapages et des contres au braquage et
voilà le but surtout pas casser la
voiture pour pâques et le voir ancien
pilote automobile jean pierre beltoise a
notamment couru 81 6 grands prix de
formule 1 et remporté celui de monaco en
1972 à sa retraite sportive il s'est
consacré à la sécurité des usagers de la
route avec des stages de prévention le
circuit jean-pierre beltoise forme
jusqu'à 10000 conducteur par an nous
sommes tout à fait voisins puisque le
circuit se trouve à trappes
et puis deuxièmement jean pierre a
toujours été très attentif à être proche
des gens à la fois localement et
peut-être même valeur dans le monde
entier deux de ces voitures étaient
présentés une monoplace de formule 3 sur
laquelle jean pierre beltoise a gagné
ses premières courses et j'ai été
utilisé au mot épreuves qu'il a
disputées 14 fois se rappelle mon
enfance ça me rappelle pas mal de choses
quoi quand j'étais jeune c'est un beau
match c'est important oui bien sûr ça
préparera partie de n'est pas cool ça me
parle beaucoup puisque on est tout près
du circuit pierre jean pierre beltoise
et c'est quelqu'un qu'on connaît
effectivement par ici jean pierre
beltoise est décédé le 5 janvier dernier
à l'âge de 77 ans et c'est déjà la fin
de cette édition reste avec nous sur
telle fille 78 tout de suite et de 7,8
sport présentée par michael elle me
d'euros je vous retrouve demain à 18
heures pour une nouvelle édition du
journal en direct je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée